i go back to your childhood
it was a wild childhood your mom even
was having this love affair with david
bowie while you were just a child is
that right
uh true yeah yeah you mean affair like
that she was still married no no she we
my my mom and dad were separated okay at
that point when your mother was having a
relationship with david bowie was that
the coolest thing that could have ever
happened how old were you um
i mean he's way cool like a nine or ten
nineteen you would see david bowie yeah
yeah he would hang out in the house
you've had a chance to work with him she
designed all his clothes so they had a
working relationship first and foremost
and then they
had a romantic relationship which really
didn't last that long it was probably
like maybe a year and a half but were
you proud of that were you like wow my
mom she was the first guy that came in
after my dad so i was pretty
apprehensive about hanging out with him
but your mom must have been a very good
looking woman she's very good-looking
here you are a young kid and your mom is
carrying on with what is a very very
famous rock star
and there were almost no rules how you
grew up yeah you didn't you one of your
mom's boyfriends do drugs with you like
heavy drugs like smoke coke with you
yeah who wow i mean you were what twelve
your mom's dating a guy
and she goes to bed or whatever
and he comes into the room
and he says let's get high
no my mom didn't know anything about it
right she wouldn't have allowed it no i
understood no he he uh
he
at some point he came to me and he's
like you know i know you do this stuff
like he was a photographer and he needed
you know misery loves company he needs
somebody to get high with what it was
and we go in the dark room and he'd get
me loaded 12 years old all night
yeah around 12 years old and go out and
uh
pillage the neighborhood until about six
o'clock seven o'clock in the morning
then i would come home
uh pretend like i was asleep and then
get up and go to school but when adults
are doing that with you oh yeah
especially it's gotta screw your whole
head up if you hadn't had the musical
gift if you hadn't been you know slashed
from guns and roses you could have
easily just ended up no money no life
well you know all things considered
that's probably that's probably true i
probably would have ended up being an
artist though because that was the
original thing that i was yeah but
you're talking about having some talent
we're saying if you had no talent yeah
the whole professional aspect of it and
the musical
uh the passion for music and all that is
what's got me to the point where i'm
still here right now you know yeah it's
amazing